next community and as you know it's a
very diverse community and we're going
to make sure that we have all facets of
it included in the waves which we go I'm
sorry sitting well look there's a lot of
a lot of infants who still looking at
that issue I'm looking forward to
meeting with both sides or multiple
sides to sit down and understand the
nuances that are not been reported in
the media but look we should be grateful
that the presidential center is coming
here but we need to make sure we can't
have development beans this place well I
think a lot of people who are
stakeholders people then haven't spoken
up people were living in those
communities and when I make sure that
they're not gonna be displaced by the
development we have to make sure
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry Oh first of all we got to make
sure that transgender people are safe
diversity as you all know there were two
transgendered women that were killed
last year their MERS go unsolved I think
it's critically important that we make
sure that the police department is doing
everything it can to protect all
communities but particularly our chances
in their community I'm meeting with the
superintendent and his team this
afternoon and it will certainly be an
issue that I raised I want to understand
what progress has been made there we
haven't we haven't however as you know
we have a number of unsolved homicides
in our city and I've met with countless
countless mothers who have lost their
children and we have to do a better job
17%
homicide clearance rates fundamentally
funding unacceptable and we will change
them well the first hundred days for me
begins today we have to get a handle on
the violence we have to make sure that
we are doing everything we can to
rebuild our network of public schools
then we need to make sure that we have
that we are a welcoming community for
immigrants that come to us from all
across the world and obviously we've got
to get a handle on issues thank you
[Applause]
the turret has I believe disrepair
I said consider coming inside the
morning giving the student the city
address she said she will write it down
whatever they may be submitted now she
processes once the bag is in prayer